quand on dit qu'on veut le retrait de la
loi et qu'on veut des négociations j'en
ai revendications c'est pas simplement
une figure de style et si la question
c'est de savoir si on veut mettre à
genoux l'économie française la réponse
elle est oui la Fédération promet une
semaine noire dans l'énergie
il y aura de nombreuses actions il y
aura des coupures ciblées il y a une
mobilisation que je respecte mais il
faut bien le dire aux françaises et aux
Français qui sont concernés dans leur
vie quotidienne justement que il y aura
un très fort impact le 7 mars peut-être
les jours suivants on le verra mais en
tout cas le 7 mars mettre la France à
l'arrêt ce serait raté le train du futur
puis mettre la France à l'arrêt ce
serait alourdir une facture déjà salée
mettre la France à l'arrêt ce serait
négligé la santé de nos enfants monsieur
verlan un peu de sérieux l'a sécheresse
c'est la faute des syndicats la crise
sanitaire idem et pourquoi pas la
défaite en Coupe du Monde vos tentatives
pour décrédibiliser une mobilisation
sans précédent contre les 64 ans son
grossières bah il a il a pas tout à fait
peur l'absence de pluie depuis plus de
30 jours maintenant en France fait peser
un risque extrêmement fort sur l'état de
nos réserves en eau cet été mettre le
pays à l'arrêt c'est prendre le risque
d'une catastrophe écologique agricole
sanitaire voire humaine on poursuivra
aussi les Robins de bois d'énergie pour
les gratuités notamment
donc nous avons décidé ou comprenez dans
mes propos de repeindre les lignes
rouges ne doit pas y avoir et n'y aura
pas de mars rouges j'aurais pu cette
expression qui est une expression qui
fait peur aux Français qui est une
expression commode pour dissimuler des
hausses qui pourraient ne pas avoir lieu
c'est pris vont augmenter en moyenne de
8 9 10% sur les semaines qui viennent
personne ne le conteste tous les
distributeurs sont d'accord avec cette
prévision là ça va piquer pour les
consommateurs je souhaite que nous ayons
dans les prochains jours un accord
collectif sur un certain nombre de
produits au prix les plus bas possible
et je souhaite que cet accord soit
appliqué au 15 mars à la réforme des
retraites arrive en effet aujourd'hui au
Sénat les sénateurs auront jusqu'au 12
mars pour voter l'ensemble du texte
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on ira
jusqu'au vote de cette réforme d'où les
cas je ferai tout pour qu'on aille
jusqu'au vote dans le respect des débats
dans le respect du droit
événement mais je pense que nous devons
français un débat bien sûr que le débat
va être rugueux mais sera respectueux il
ira bien sûr qu'il sera passionné mais
il sera aussi raisonné au Sénat on n'a
pas le même esprit pardon qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale il y aura pas
d'injures personne ne sera traité de
voleur ou d'assassin l'assemblée ce sont
les insoumis qui se sont très mal
comportés ici ce sera pas le cas parce
qu'il y en a pas le choix est clair soit
on a recours à l'immigration et c'est ce
qui est fait aujourd'hui soit on met en
place une politique nataliste exactement
vous êtes d'accord je sais qu'ici par de
là les parcours de chacun on se respecte
je sais qu'ici il n'y a pas de ZAD il
n'y a que la République ça laisse avec
le fait de tenir exactement le même
discours que le RN sur ce sujet j'en ai
marre j'en ai marre de de ces
commentateurs que vous êtes non
monsieur Bardella a dit hier qu'à minuit
il faisait noir bah oui moi je dis qu'à
minuit il faisait noir et alors
l'environnement le futur de la planète
sont au cœur du sommet qui se tient
actuellement au Gabon préserver les
forêts tropicales Emmanuel Macron
présent sur place a également abordé un
autre sujet notre histoire commune ici
au Gabon ne nous le cachons pas c'est
aussi celle de la France Afrique et cet
âge de la France Afrique et bien révolu
puis la sentence royale qui est tombée
Charles III retire à son fils Harry et
sa femme Mégane l'usage de leur
résidence britannique à Windsor le
couple installé aux États-Unis aurait-il
dépassé les bornes des limites avec son
grand déballage médiatique je suis venu
investir personne je ne suis venu
témoigner que mon amitié ma
considération un pays et un peuple frère
doit-on avoir peur de toi chat chez BD
il est important de comprendre que je
suis un programme informatique et donc
je n'ai pas de sentiments ou d'intention
je n'ai pas la capacité de causer du mal
ou de nuire à qui que ce soit
spectaculaire incendie dans un immeuble
de centre-ville à Buffalo aux États-Unis
un feu d'une grande violence qui a été
suivie par une explosion cependant il
est important de ssurer que les
informations que je fournis sont
utilisées de manière responsable